[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días
este es un magazine informativo dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
amalbert man y estos son los titulares
las consecuencias alimentarias de la
guerra de ucrania ya se sienten en
áfrica analizaremos este tema con bueno
para noche especialista en agricultura y
alimentación se cumplieron 60 años de
los acuerdos de helio un momento crucial
en la historia de la colonización
francesa firmados por argelia y francia
pusieron fin a ocho años de una guerra
mortífera por la independencia del país
norteafricano
tras casi un año de disputa por el
conflicto del sahara occidental
madrid- hizo las bases con rabat una
decisión es rechazada por argel
ampliaremos con nuestra corresponsal en
marrakech sofía catalán
la zona de conflicto puede parecer
lejana pero las consecuencias de la
guerra en ucrania tiene un fuerte
impacto en el continente africano casi
un mes después del inicio de la invasión
el precio de los alimentos básicos
continúa aumentando y en consecuencia
también la preocupación por la seguridad
alimentaria en el continente en ucrania
y en el suroeste de rusia se encuentran
unas de las tierras más fértiles del
mundo ambos países generan conjuntamente
alrededor del 14 por ciento de la
producción mundial de trigo y casi el
40% de las exportaciones
internacionales de este cereal en este
mapa podemos ver en color amarillo los
países africanos que importan desde
rusia y ucrania la totalidad en paz del
90 por ciento de su trigo
el 14 de marzo el secretario general de
la onu antonio guterres
advirtió sobre un posible huracán de
hambre en áfrica para entenderlo
preguntamos a bueno está noche experto
en agricultura y alimentación porque
tantos países africanos dependen del
trigo de rusia y de ucrania y qué riesgo
corren ante la situación actual
en áfrica no hay ni un un solo país que
está realmente bueno en agricultura y
que está capable de exportar es muy
diferente la situación en américa latina
tienen países que tienen muy buena
agricultura y que exportan como brasil o
argentina entonces la mayor parte de los
países africanos deben de comprar su
comida y sobre todo los de áfrica del
norte porque ellos comen trigo comentan
y comen cuscús que no pueden producirlo
cuando quieres comprar trigo dónde vas a
comprar vas a comprar en los pocos
países que están capaz de producir más
que lo que comen ahora rusia y ucrania
holanda solamente producen 15% del del
trigo del mundo pero aseguran 40% de las
exportaciones o sea si quieres comprar
trigo pues fatalmente vas a ucrania y
vas a rusia y por supuesto el trigo de
ucrania
ya no está disponible
es la guerra y va a durar porque los
puertos están bombardeados y no es
seguro que siembran y no es seguro que
cosechan y no hay suficiente trigo a
través del mundo para reemplazar o sea
el precio de los cereales va a aumentar
mucho y la disponibilidad de todos más
bastante escasa esta crisis esta escasez
de cereales va a durar uno o dos años y
entonces es muy grave porque no hay
suficiente reservas para nutrirse
sigamos analizando las consecuencias de
la guerra en ucrania decenas de
ciudadanos cameruneses siguen varados en
ciudades ucranianas son estudiantes
trabajadores pero también familias con
niños que se encuentran sin perspectivas
de ser evacuados al momento sus pedidos
de ayuda a las autoridades de camerún
han quedado sin respuesta
entonces complementen al ser solucionada
gracias a vídeos grabados con sus
teléfonos decenas de cameruneses como
adrien un marinero de 35 años que llegó
a ucrania hace más de 10 años dan
testimonio de su difícil vida cotidiana
desde que empezó la guerra una de las
acciones de uruguay es el bus tuvimos la
suerte de poder hacer algunas compras
pudimos conseguir arroz azúcar y harina
pero ya no hay pan en la ciudad no queda
nada sólo comemos una vez al día así que
con los niños es muy complicado se trata
de cumplir son familias y estudiantes
cameruneses que dicen haber pedido ayuda
a su gobierno para ser evacuados pero lo
único que recibieron fue este simple
comunicado en el que se les pide que
tuvieran cuidado y siguieran las
instrucciones de las autoridades
ucranianas
llamamos hicimos todo lo posible con las
embajadas las autoridades pero lo único
que nos dicen es que esperemos esperemos
y esperemos y estamos esperando pero no
tenemos comida no tenemos agua y tenemos
mucho miedo les quiero a cinco mil
kilómetros de distancia en este suburbio
capital camerunesa go al a la familia de
adrián vive en la confusión tras
marcharse a europa en busca de una vida
mejor el joven mantiene a su familia y
paga la asistencia de salud de su padre
que padece la enfermedad de parkinson
ver las noticias o chatear con su hijo
por whatsapp se ha convertido en la
única forma de esperanza para sus padres
esperanza de que las autoridades tomen
medidas concretas para evacuar a las
personas atrapadas en ucrania
cuando dejas a tu hijo irse al
extranjero en busca de una vida mejor y
se ve atrapado en una guerra como puedes
sentirte estamos llorando él es el gran
apoyo de la familia es el que hace casi
todo por nosotros estamos rogando a las
jóvenes y a las organizaciones
humanitarias y al gobierno camerunés lo
que saque a nuestros hijos de este lío
si nos dan fan de usted desee petra
desde que rusia lanzó un ataque contra
ucrania el 24 de febrero los ciudadanos
cameruneses han muerto
realmente una con ansias
este 18 de marzo se cumplieron 60 años
del fin de la guerra en argelia fue n
dio suiza en 1962 donde se firmó el
acuerdo de cese el fuego entre el país
norteafricano y francia su potencia
colonizadora la guerra de argelia fue la
trágica salida a más de 130 años de
colonización francesa y dejó cicatrices
psicológicas y políticas duraderas en
las sociedades de ambos países
se necesitaron meses de negociaciones
secretas previas y la aceleración de los
atentados en argel y parís a principios
de 1962 para que finalmente después de
ocho años de guerra cruenta las
conversaciones de piano se inaugurarán
oficialmente el 7 de marzo de 1962 entre
el gobierno francés y el ala política
del frente de liberación nacional la
conferencia duró 11 días las
conversaciones se estancaron
notablemente en dos temas el futuro de
la comunidad francesa residente en
argelia que finalmente no fue resuelto
por el acuerdo y la cuestión de la
soberanía del sahara parís exigió y
consiguió mantener durante varios años
el control de la región donde los
intereses petroleros y nucleares
franceses eran importantes
[Música]
el 18 de marzo de 1962 se firmaron los
acuerdos de viaje con un alto el fuego
que entró en vigor al mediodía del día
siguiente esa misma noche el general de
gaulle se dirigió a los franceses lo a
es
la perspectiva y su las disposiciones se
adaptan para que las poblaciones puedan
disponer de su destino y la perspectiva
del procedimiento de un ángel
independiente cooperando estrechamente
con nosotros satisface la razón de
formular eso pedazos
en realidad la violencia continuarían
largos meses
lado a ese organización armada
clandestina formada por los partidos de
argelia francesa multiplicó los ataques
nfl n tomó represalias con asesinatos y
secuestros de europeos sospechosos de
estar cerca de la organización pero el
proceso de independencia previsto en los
acuerdos debía era inevitable en medio
de la atención el primero de julio de
1962 la población votó masivamente por
el sí a la independencia de argelia el
mismo día de una jornada sangrienta la
masacre de orán la inseguridad y la
violencia provocaron el éxodo hacia la
metrópoli de casi un millón de pies no a
pies negros personas de origen francés
que vivían en argelia en los barcos
había también unos 10.000 harkis
argelinos que hicieron parte del
ejército francés que permanecieron en
argelia y fueron a menudo víctimas de
represalias una dolorosa repatriación
cuyas heridas aún se sienten hoy en día
el conflicto del sáhara occidental
antigua colonia española enfrenta desde
hace décadas a marc huecos con los
independentistas saharauis del frente
polisario y el año pasado la acogida en
españa del líder del frente polisario
para que recibiera tratamiento contra el
kobe 19 creó una inédita disputa entre
madrid y rabat sin embargo el viernes 18
de marzo españa y marruecos hicieron las
paces nuestra corresponsal en marrakech
sofía catalán nos amplía
por primera vez el gobierno de españa'
ha tomado partido públicamente por el
estado marroquí en el conflicto del
sáhara occidental' el presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez comunicó al rey
mohamed sexto que españa considera el
proyecto de autonomía que propone
marruecos para el sahara como la opción
más realista dijo para resolver el
conflicto excluyendo el referéndum de
autodeterminación que exige la otra
parte el frente polisario y esto es muy
importante porque ante naciones unidas
españa sigue siendo administradora de
este territorio que ocupó hasta el año
1975 y que se considera una pendiente de
descolonización pero de facto es
marruecos quien administra el sáhara
desde hace más de 40 años cuando españa
le cedió el territorio estallando así el
conflicto con el frente polisario que a
su vez ahora que acusa a españa de
sucumbir a dicen al chantaje de
marruecos y con la declaración de españa
se da por finalizada la sonada crisis
diplomática que españa y marruecos han
mantenido en el último año pero se abre
un nuevo escenario de crisis y es que
argelia principal valedor del frente
polisario ha llamado a consultas a su
embajador en madrid atrás enterarse de
lo que han considerado que una segunda
traición histórica dicen de españa'
hacia el pueblo saharaui
también el gobierno argelino asegura que
no fueron informados de la decisión
antes de hacerse pública cosa que
desmiente exteriores de españa que
aseguran que sí informaron a su socio
argelino y está preocupa mucho en españa
porque es que argelia es precisamente
uno de sus principales proveedores de
gas naturales temen que la crisis pueda
traducirse en el cierre de la suministro
por parte de argelia y todo esto sucede
en un contexto de presión histórica por
parte de marruecos hacia los países
europeos que tienen empresas operando en
el sáhara desde hace años de hecho antes
de españa' alemania fue el último país
europeo en pronunciarse a favor del plan
de autonomía marroquí para el sáhara
tras también mantener una crisis
diplomática con este país y por otra
parte cabe destacar que la última
resolución del consejo de seguridad
también excluye el referéndum de
autodeterminación acercándose así a las
tesis de marruecos para resolver el
conflicto
y para cerrar cambiamos de tema
el burkinés francis quiere se ha
convertido en el primer arquitecto
africano en recibir el prestigioso
premio pritzker de arquitectura fue
premiado por sus obras contemporáneas
sostenibles sociales y respetuosas con
el medio ambiente que renació en burkina
faso en una aldea sin escuela su familia
lo envió a aprender a leer y escribir a
20 kilómetros de su casa en el aula en
el que pasaba sus días los niños se
asignaban en un ambiente asfixiante y
sin luz esta experiencia de la infancia
lo inspiró y una vez convertido en
arquitecto su primera iniciativa fue
ofrecer a los niños de su pueblo una
escuela merecedora de tal nombre
los dejamos con las imágenes de la obra
de francis quiere gracias por
acompañarnos y siguen con nosotros en
holt 24 y fondos 24 puntocom
[Música]